sponge with fresh ginger bacon is part
chemistry part imagination but you've
got to rely on the rules for great
results it's the only time you'll see me
reaching for the scales
first off eggs sugar butter and when I
say weigh out the ingredients it does
literally mean way out to the final Gram
175. now 175 grams of sugar that's 350
grams in total cream the butter and the
sugar
let's get a delicious light sponge start
carefully on slow speed
[Music]
only speed up as a butter and sugar
really start to cream together
keep that really nice and light you can
see how it's changed color so important
at the beginning
eggs in
a little whisk
adding one egg at a time stops the mix
from separating second again
third one in
[Music]
that's what we're looking for a really
nice sort of light area detection
now I've got a flavor the sponge a
little teaspoon of vanilla extract like
perfumes the mix one teaspoon of baking
powder that gives lightness 175 grams of
flour and we're going to sieve it a to
get rid of any lumps and B to keep it
really nice and fine
we're not going to beat that out we're
just going to lightly fold that in now
what I'm looking for is a really nice
loose dough that's looking a little bit
too firm so just a little splash of milk
a couple of tablespoons that relaxes the
mixture down
helps create that nice almost dropping
consistency
that's what I want
yeah it's starting to drop take a
non-stick loose bottom cake tin
greasy with butter then coat it with
flour to avoid the sponge sticking
give that animal shake
all the rim
now just get the back of the spatula
make sure you've got no Peaks on my
sponge
to make sure the sponge bakes nice and
evenly tap the tin a few times to knock
out any air pockets that might have
formed in the mixture
now into the oven bake for 30 to 35
minutes at 180 degrees
as that's cooking prepare the ginger
cream for the center 300 mL of cream
give that a nice whisk
whisking cream by hand gives you so much
more control and it's so easy to over
whip cream I want that nice light Ginger
cream in the center I don't want it
grainy nothing worse when cream starts
to separate now let's get into that
three-quarter stage little stiff peaks
stop that for two minutes press Ginger
now get a really nice large slice of
ginger smells incredible
so fragrant even Ginger is like sort of
peanut potato it's just take out all
those little dark spots
now get your grater
you haven't got a grate you can chop the
ginger really finely
I've got almost like a puree of Ginger
going through but the juice as well take
your knife
just scrape all that
taste
it's incredible
fragrant it's not sweet it's got a
really nice taste set that in the fridge
[Music]
smells incredible
run a knife around the outside to ensure
the cake doesn't stick to the tin before
turning it out
yeah get your hands under push
and out
why your cake cools I'm gonna do like a
really nice sweet chocolate coating pour
300 mL of double cream into a saucepan
add two tablespoons of golden syrup to
make the top nice and glossy then whisk
chop this up really thinly
so as it melts quickly
50 grams of butter that's going to give
the chocolate a really nice shine
boil your cream and
mix it in
give that a really good stir as a
chocolate the butter melts it thickens
look how shiny that is
so nice to finish with something sweet
on top
ping done time to build your sponge cake
look at the halfway mark there
just gently slice
and really take your time all the way
through
lift
that's delicious
a nice big dollop in the middle it'll be
stingy don't be tight with a cream
another dollop on top spread that
very carefully
lift the lid and just sit there on top
that's why I start off with a little
extra cream in there so I want to squash
it down the cream just pushes out to the
side
I'm not finished
poor the luxurious chocolate topping
over the sponge
be generous and make sure the cake is
coated thoroughly to give it a gorgeous
finish get the bottom of the ladle and
spread
whoa
one more
[Music]
you'll know when to say stop and
something looks that delicious
I just want to dive in there
[Music]
wonderful baked cheesecake for me food
always has to be impressive but when it
comes to desserts often you see Sponge
sugar or wild decorations remember
simple is always the most impressive
this cheesecake is so straightforward
yet so delicious
cream cheese leave it out of the fridge
for five or ten minutes go nice and soft
trust me your arms will be thanking you
sugar in this cheesecake is the New York
cheesecake because it's baked so there's
no base start creaming the cheese and
the sugar
spending the amount of time I do in the
states if there's one thing they know
how to do out there is the most amazing
impressive cheesecake Rich delicious but
so simple work the bowl
lift the ball to your advantage
really whisk
whisk whisk whisk
lovely
creamy now
get your eggs
add the extra mixture bit by bit doing
it this way it's more efficient hey
you're incorporating a lot of Air B the
mixture doesn't separate
the last of your egg
of course you can use electric mixer but
why go to the gym we can just make a
cheesecake a day
keep the Bingo Wings away
now a couple of tablespoons of flour
give it a whisk stop something going
Lumpy
now I want to scent that cheesecake
I've got the freshness zest of the lemon
in there I want to sort of tart it up
even more fold in some fresh raspberries
so just mix them through be careful to
crush them
then Grease the cake tin with butter
this will ensure your cheesecake slides
out beautifully
get your mix
let that fall in
now take your cake tin and just
tap it
mixture hits the bottom of the cake tin
the rasp is rise and you've got
raspberries at the top the middle and
the bottom it also stops all those
little pockets of air trapping
underneath the mixture and the cake tin
there's no holes
in the cheesecake now into the oven 180
degrees for 35 to 40 minutes
[Music]
foreign
slightly soufflaid up
pull off
[Music]
that's the color I wanted on top
and look at it
it's one of the simplest yet the most
stylish cheesecakes anywhere
beautiful
[Music]